easy no sudden moves let's just wait
until it decides to get up again okay
but we're gonna get through this love
death and robots is this kind of
creative jam session from artists around
the world this show is truly one of a
kind the only thing we can think of that
even parallels it is black mirror and
even then love death and robots takes it
all a million steps further
have you ever seen anything like this
ever
so today we're taking a look at all the
hurdles they had to jump over to get
this animated masterpiece in shape
number one the concept for the show was
simple the execution less so creator tim
miller wanted to do animation for adults
we want to show that animation is not
just for kids it's just medium for
storytelling
nothing was off the table gore violence
intimacy the different stories lent
themselves to different animation styles
the hallmark of the show is the variety
so the team outsourced to many different
animation studios across the globe that
could honor the stories miller wanted to
tell and bring their own cultural flair
almost every company put in more time
than they were paid to do because they
wanted to make the work great we had a
huge [ __ ] list of
potential stories and these were the
ones that we thought oh well this is
gonna work most of the episodes have
different directors and given that the
episodes are being outsourced to
companies all over the world this led to
a language barrier at times but also a
very unique collaboration process with
artists sharing a wealth of techniques
and insights number two if the hills
have eyes then the grass has personality
the tall grass was designed to look like
nothing anyone's ever seen before one of
the main characters was the grass every
interaction between the characters and
the grass had to be hand animated to get
the look they were going for they worked
on every second frame instead of every
frame to get a bit of a stop-motion feel
when the lights hit the characters there
are sharper edges and shadows to give
the sense of loose paint rather than
smooth cg best not to mention this to
anyone
they won't believe you anyway number
three come retire at sunset city where
you never have to fight with your family
again just your vacuum the characters
were designed to feel like puppets in a
dollhouse the production company meat
department used the designs of the
people as their inspiration for the
robots while the humans were super
fleshy the robots contrasted that by
being minimalistic and sleek
congratulations you stopped the
unstoppable killing machine that is
vacubot number four the characters in
ice were as cold as their environment
the team who worked on volume one's zima
blue also worked on ice the director
robert valley was excited to play around
with more action although the short
isn't all about action but human
condition and relationships it's more of
stand by me meets giant frost whales
number five you think actors kissing
during covid was challenging try motion
capture on for size the most challenging
part of snow in the desert was creating
the characters the studio unit image
scanned the actors for all of the
expressions they could ever need and
recording the mocap for kissing and
animation is incredibly tricky the
actors didn't touch each other
i mean you know harm
unless harm is meant
number six he sees you when you're
sleeping he knows when you're awake
santa was always creepy this was love
death and robot's first stop motion
short there's a level of tactility you
can't emulate creator tim miller
absolutely hates christmas but after
stumbling upon this story he just had to
include it miller loved messing with
people's minds in this short it wasn't
all done with stop motion though their
facial expressions and santa's saliva
were refined using cgi
did you hear that
number seven you ain't got nothing if
you don't have a character worth rooting
for the live action and animation is
integrated so seamlessly you may have a
hard time telling who is the real
michael b jordan and who is all cgi
biggest challenge of this show was
creating the photo reel digi double of
michael b jordan and he got involved
because he'd binge watched the show and
just wanted to let tim miller know how
much he loved it this very quickly
turned into work for the actor despite
the huge feat that sci-fi is blur studio
wanted to keep this story simple and
intense so much of the story happens
like right here on this guy's face
number eight we would watch a whole pop
squad movie pop squad is part blade
runner and part noir another animation
by blur studio explores what would
happen to society if nothing ever ended
i hope that it makes people examine what
gives life meaning number nine we were
left with more questions than answers on
this one i wanted to do it as close to
realistic as possible tim miller swore
to himself he wouldn't mess up telling
this story making the animation as close
to true life as possible was very
intentional the mystery was in the
detail miller did his best to make it as
close to jg ballard's original version
his daughter wrote to tim to say that
her dad would have loved it
number 10 you know what's no secret how
hard it is to animate a horse but is it
harder than animating creepy alien
thingies most definitely the majestic
creature can look clunky if not handled
with care digit pictures had to tailor a
special mocap suit for a live horse
number 11. is it a helping hand if it's
your hand helping out helping hand
stands out from the rest in how minimal
it is it's even more minimal than
lifehutch john yeo and axe's studio
wanted to strip the story back as far as
they could to make sure it was only
about human emotion with every pass at
the animation they kept adding more
teeny tiny details like fridge magnets
and post-it notes to make the space feel
lived in it's really fun to know that
it's there and that it's kind of just
background noise the facial performance
was the most important element all of
the little details on the character's
face were added by hand and they
animated over top of the footage number
12 the composer may have had the biggest
job of anyone when you're building the
sound for a show each episode has its
requirements but generally the sound
palette and the approach are unified but
when it comes to an anthology series
especially love death and robots which
has such a huge range that makes the
stylistic range in the music enormous
the role of composer belonged to rob
cairns for the episode the dump cairns
built an entire musical palette out of
his version of a junkyard band where
everything except for a harmonica and
the dobro were broken instruments or
something played wrong he even played a
bass dulcimer with a cello bow and hit
it with a hammer for sunny's edge which
has a gritty cyberpunk vibe cairns
avoided the synth wave the stereotypical
sci-fi instrument show me what you got
big boy
now on to lucky number 13 it's no
coincidence we put this episode here
this was the first episode that was
shown to other creators with such a high
bar set it's no wonder the entire season
is so binge-worthy this short took
inspiration from war movies like black
hawk down and saving private ryan
number 14. what do robots hitler and
yogurt have in common they were the
leads in john scalzi's animated the
source material was so over the top
crazy it was just embrace it and go for
it they enjoyed playing around with the
different animation styles number 15.
the rest of volume 1 gets one big huge
honorable mention because the show's
range is too vast to just skip over an
episode more than any other creative
endeavor animation takes a village so
we're just taking a quick peek at what
lies behind all of the incredible
episodes we haven't already covered
breathtaking
it's more beautiful than in the
brochures
animators need more outlets to animate
for adults it's truly just one medium of
storytelling and love death and robots
proves that there are animated adult
stories to be explored do you have a
favorite episode three robots is high on
our list because that baby monitor is
just too precious but how about you let
us know your favorite episode in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things